Helena Thiessen spends hours recalling
the past her childhood memories are
vivid she still remembers when the two
men came to take her from her little
house you nuke the capital of Greenland
70 years ago she was taken to a ship
preparing to sail for a long journey to
Denmark why
should I
go
leave my mother why didn't my mother
said yes to that I feel me so lonely and
when we go to bed I every night or
crying Helena was among 22 Inuit
children chosen for a social experiment
carried out by Danish authorities in
1951. the goal was to turn orphan
children into members of a modern
Greenland but not all of them were
orphans when they arrived in Copenhagen
some were sent to an orphanage and
others to Foster families journalist
Anna Christian Hermann says the
experiment was part of a Danish scheme
in the 1950s to maintain control over
its former Arctic Colony So the plan was
to show the rest of the world that
Greenland was a natural part of Denmark
and needed to remain part of Denmark
through integration rather than autonomy
and this is where the children come into
the picture Helena spent almost two
years in Denmark she was told never to
use greenlandic language and when she
later went home she struggled to to
communicate with her family members why
didn't she answer me
and then a little after she answered me
and said something
and it was like
my life
broken because I could not understand
her
the experiment was a failure by the time
the children were reunited with their
families two years later they say they
felt traumatized their childhoods
shattered
it took the government decades to
apologize but Helena still feels angry
and hurt it will always be
a very
very bad thing in our hearts it will
never go away only six of those forced
to take part in the experiment are still
alive we know little about the others
apart from some who suffered mental
health problems and alcohol abuse and
one who took his own life
Helena's life would never be the same
again she never managed to reconcile
with her mother who couldn't overcome
the regret of letting her child be taken
away from her a story that serve as a
reminder of what Helena describes as a
dark chapter in Denmark's history
Copenhagen